yep that's because they're reese
witherspoon and ryan phillippe i was
like this is gonna be good on saturday
the former couple who split in 2006
reunited for their son deacon's 18th
birthday and both shared heartwarming
tributes on social media to their baby
boy who is now officially an adult as
they grow and mature and evolve your
relationship with them does as well ryan
took to instagram with these photos
where you can see the two posing
together with beacon in the middle and
captioned it quote happy 18th birthday
to our gorgeous smart talented and
caring son you are a true light in this
world and are so loved by all who know
you we are lucky to be your mom and dad
love you pup i'd say we did pretty good
at reese witherspoon
thank you meanwhile the legally blonde
star shared some beautiful photos of
deacon throughout the years including
this adorable throwback pic of deacon as
a little boy posing next to his mama in
this shot of the 18 year old musician
preparing to blow out his candles my
kids are the best gift in my life we've
captioned it all quote how did this
happen deacon is 18.
one day he was trading pokemon cards
singing bruno mars songs and playing
american ninja warrior in the backyard
the next day he's taller than me cooking
the family steaks on the grill and
making his own music with his best
friends
my heart is bursting with pride about
the young man he is becoming happy 18th
birthday deacon i love you to the moon
around the sun and all the stars hey
that's a lot of love right there
why are you trying to make me cry rhys
and ryan who also shared 22 year old
daughter ava philippe together were
married for seven years before splitting
in 2006. i'm very very lucky yeah to
have healthy amazing children the 45
year old actress also shares her
nine-year-old son tennessee james who
you can see is right next to his big
brother in this photo with husband jim
top who she married in 2011.
i don't think any parent gets the
ultimate cool card back in 2017 ryan
opened up to e.t about the one wish he
has for his kids fulfillment that
they're happy with with
their direction in life and he reacted
to all the comments about how ava and
deacon are spitting images of him and
rhys i mean it's weird because like
isn't that obvious who else are they
going to look like you know
i think i always find that such a weird
thing like she looks exactly like her
mother who else is she going to look
like i know it's an odd thing that
people fixate on that but you know i
i've i i wonder sometimes like wow they
feel about it we talk about it too but i
think we've all made peace with the fact
that we're out there in the public and
that people are going to choose to key
on
whatever is interesting to them it may
not be interesting to us it's not
something we don't sit around talking
about how much we look
[Music]
you